irgendwer ist am wahlabend klar kanzler
und hat die wahl gewonnen und wir haben
einen kanzler oder eine kanzlerin
gewählt das verschafft einem ja auch
irgendwie das gefühl von sicherheit und
geborgenheit und dann kümmert sich
jemand wie sie gerade gesagt haben ja
wer regiert denn dann und ich glaube mit
der frage sitzen gerade ganz viele leute
zu hause und sagen es ist diesem land
eigentlich das erste mal nicht gelungen
uns irgendwie zu vereinen und zu
versöhnen hinter der einen figur es ist
komplett zersplittert ja bei der
politiker gibt es ja zurück an diese
bürger und sagt das ist der wille des
bürgers auch wenn kein wille erkennbar
ist
das ist genau der punkt es ist kein es
ist tatsächlich kein wille erkennbar ja
und das ist eine vollkommen neue
situation und ich glaube genau diese
situation ja machtmenschen ein bisschen
ratlos und
gerade nach wie diesen anderthalb jahren
der pandemie werde glaube ich klarheit
wünschenswerte gewesen und übrigens auch
aus meiner sicht kleid heute abend ja
dann hätte man gesagt weil sie das weil
sie hätte das viele menschen vielleicht
geheißen das gefühl geben hallo wie
schätzen sie das ein bisschen stimmung
gerade in deutschland wir haben die
pandemie noch nicht ganz hinter uns
gebracht jetzt sitzen wir heute an
diesem historischen abend da und wissen
nicht wie geht es weiter mit deutschland
geworden
war das ganze ja nicht in deutschland
sonnig war in kitzbühel weil ich mich da
aufgehalten habe mit meiner frau und wir
haben das alles corona haben wir zwar
mitgekriegt wir haben auch gelitten
darunter das heißt ich konnte auch
nirgendwo hingehen ohne mal ohne maske
nur mit maske heute ja auch wieder das
ist zwar sehr traurige stimmung ist eher
traurig in
bei uns in deutschland und wie gesagt
jetzt sind die politiker die gewählt
worden sind die können jetzt mal zeigen
was uns alle versprochen aber massa alle
von halten wie ich bin jetzt 83 in
profitieren nicht mehr viel davon aber
die jungen leute die jetzt alle
nachkommen die müssen noch wissen wen
sie wählen oder woran sie sich halten
woran sie sich stützen mein leben ist
gelaufen wir hatten ja neulich ein
faszinierender kinogeschichte bei uns in
der bild zeitung da ging es darum dass
sie ein dass sie auftreten wollten mit
dem deutschen lieder und unter den
farben schwarz rot gold und das wurde
nicht erlaubt ja alles hieß das ist
deutsch ziemlich das ist nationalistisch
das volk eben nicht erlaubt wenn der
staat von der spanischen alicante
intendanten genau warum genutzt hatte
die amerikaner schwenken ihre frage wann
immer es geht weil baseball das
gewaltspiel aber und ich finde das sagt
so viel die frage ist doch das sei hier
jeder möchte ich eigentlich überall mit
ein so dass du selber gar nicht mehr die
entscheidung treffen kannst du möchtest
diesen abend gestalten so eine wahl ist
ja auch immer eigentlichen biete die
möglichkeit oder könnten die möglichkeit
geben zu vereinen stolz zu sein die die
person zu finden die durch sprache zum
beispiel durch sein ganzes oder ihr
ganzes verhalten menschen zusammenführt
wo die einen sagen ich will hören und
die anderen sagen dann bist du aber
national ist wenn du wenn du dir nur
diese lieder an wirst wie absurd ist es
geworden ja und davon hören davon ist
heute abend ja eigentlich nichts übrig
geblieben von dieser hoffnung das ist
dass es einen ausweg über eine person da
gibt ja ich bin ja immer damit
konfrontiert worden schon
schon seit jahren mit meiner meiner
ersten platten die ich gemacht habe also
schon gekommen rechnung und so muss zur
damaligen zeit noch gar nie was ein
rechter und war so ein linker war wäre
ich hab mich für politik überhaupt gar
nicht interessiert ich habe mich für das
interessieren weil sie gesungen habe
aber dass das liedgut so angefeindet
worden ist und das
1977 sollte ich schon das
bundesverdienstkreuz bekommen hieß es
geht nicht dein opa in afrika aber vor
mir war james last ich bin
alle waren in afrika vom so richtig da
singen so und dass das ich habe das nie
ich habe das nie begriffen das hat sich
bis zum heutigen tag hat sich das immer
so
durchgezogen hatte heiner der muss der
eine muss
[Musik]